[Music]
just like the titular Cobra Kai the
drama Never Dies Cobra Kai season 5
knows how to keep its fans guessing
in many ways a cobra Kai's brand value
is at an all-time high Cherry Silva
infused plenty of capital to give the
dojo a modern facelift also he expanded
marketing and began acquiring other
Dojos to create a karate Monopoly in the
valley Terry's ultimate goal is to go
Global after a stellar win of the saikai
taikai World Tournament of course now
that Stingray has altered his statement
of events concerning the assault he
suffered at the hands of Terry the
conniving karate master is now looking
at serious time behind bars or is he so
he is after all a wealthy man who likely
has connections to the finest lawyers in
the valley still Cobra Kai is leaderless
for the time being as the main Dojo sees
a mass Exodus of karate students after
Terry is revealed as a cheater however
the other Dojos Terry acquired are still
standing but who will operate them and
could Kim daeun take control of Cobra
Kai
for a moment it seems like everything
would end with a grand Face-Off in yet
another tournament only this time the
combat would play out on the world stage
Terry courts the tournament officials to
have his dojo accepted as a participant
the end game Terry has a sight set on
kobakai achieving global domination as
his goal is to establish a dojo that
will become an Empire to achieve this he
would need the cloud that comes with
winning the prestigious Sakai taikai
tournament through a bit of manipulation
on Daniel's part the heroes learn from
crease exactly what Terry's Ambitions
are Daniel Johnny and chosen interrupt
Terry's meetings with the Sakai taikai
officials in an effort to become
participants themselves the matchup ends
with both Dojo securing a win and being
granted entry into the tournament as the
season ends with a takedown of cherry
Silva and most of the main Cobra Kai
dojos membership disbanded their
entrance into the Sakai Tai Kai
tournament hangs in the balance however
it's possible that with new leadership
in charge a group of fresh face Fighters
could rise up to face the challenge
after all Cobra Kai Never Dies so it's
always possible that the dojo could
still make an appearance at the global
tournament
[Music]
no one may like John Crees for the
torment he inflicted on those who
challenged him but he has technically
been jailed and justly and doesn't
belong in prison he is framed for a
crime he didn't commit by his longtime
friend Terry the same man who assault
Stingray and nearly beats him into the
grave Stingray makes amends by
explaining to the authorities that Terry
was the actual perpetrator and that's
his original accusation was made under
duress and threat of reprisal now that
stingray's testimony of the incident has
changed but Chris's sentence be commuted
whether this happens or not crease just
broke out of prison which carries its
own set of consequences if he would have
just waited a little longer he might
have got out legally now Chris is an
escapes convict still he seems to have
his eye on the prize what is that prize
exactly Freedom Cobra Kai suddenly he
can't just Waltz into a cobra Kai dojo
and take over again like nothing ever
happened for one he'd be reported as a
fugitive second no one would give him
the time of day after what Terry has
done to the Dojo students and Affiliates
however Chris seems to have some tricks
up his sleeve Daniel and Johnny don't do
themselves any favors when they drive a
wedge between themselves and the former
Sensei Daniel promises Chris her use of
his lawyer should Chris reveal Terry's
end game crease lives up to his part of
the bargain but Daniel doesn't honor his
word priesto made that mistake again
everything Chris does from here on Earth
will likely be illegal and aggressive
given that he's a wanted man so just
what exactly is Chris planning next it
certainly won't be good
season five saw the delightful return of
chosen a former Nemesis of Daniel
Larusso of course now Chozen is an ally
and friend having accepted Daniel's Act
of Mercy when they were young Chozen has
been brought Stateside by Daniel to help
thwart Terry Silva's Grand schemes that
said the Okinawan fighter is a bit
overzealous in his role as Daniel's
sidekick it sometimes gets him in
trouble such as when he attacks Mike
Barnes before learning that Mike is an
ex-cobra kai fighter who now runs a
furniture store still Chozen is a good
loyal friend to Daniel and even shrugs
up a friendship with Johnny in a
vulnerable moment with Johnny chosen
reveals that he is in love with a woman
named Kumiko Daniel knows exactly who
Kumiko is as she was Daniel's love
interest to join the events of The
Karate Kid Part 2 when Daniel
accompanied Mr Miyagi on a trip to his
home of Okinawa Daniel met Kumiko and
the two became Inseparable the pair even
met once again in their adult years
however Chozen having grown up in the
same Village apparently always had a fun
nurse for Kumiko Daniel encourages
Chozen to pursue her and chosen does so
by leaving her a drunken but endearing
voicemail which chosen find a bit of
happiness and connect with Kumiko upon
his event to return to Okinawa let's
hope we get to see a happy ending to
that story okay bye
once again Daniel and Johnny put
everything on the line as they prepare
their students for a fight with Cobra
Kai this time however the fight's
results will determine whether they
would have a place in the global Sakai
taikai tournament Hawk has chosen as a
male fighter and Sam naturally takes
Center Stage as a female fighter Hawk
loses as bows with Kenny due to some
shady calls from the referee and the
bruise Albert's apparently legal strike
to his sternum to get around the
compromise referee some must make each
point she scores clear and undeniable
she succeeds and impresses the Sakai
taikai officials enough to allow her
Dojo to come aboard however when Daniel
and Johnny are asked what the dojo's
name is they offer up both Miyagi dough
and Eagle Fang they want to recognize
that their Dojo is a melding of two
opposing philosophies that came together
and managed to find Common Ground as
such they formed a unique mixed style
while the officials acknowledge the
legacy of their group they still require
a single name for entry however they
didn't need the name right away meaning
that Johnny and Daniel can get back to
them later despite accomplishing their
ultimate goal of defeating Terry Silva
there's no way Daniel and Johnny will
pass on the opportunity to compete in
the global Arena so what will their Dojo
be called will they officially adopt
Miyagi Fang or will they come up with a
new name altogether knowing how these
two big hero belts absolutely everything
maybe then they might become a point of
contention in season six
Kenny Payne may be small but he quickly
proves that size isn't everything for a
time he was relentlessly bullied by
Anthony Larusso and his Pals he carries
that pain with him into the next chapter
of his life as a karate master Robbie
takes Kenny under his wing in kobakai to
help him to master his abilities as a
fighter to defend himself later Robbie
realizes how detrimental Cobra Kai is to
the members and leaves however Kenny
stays and quickly turns his Newfound
skills into a tool for his rage then he
flips the script and starts bullying
others in season five because you're
gonna be in the world
all right
Kenny shows his ruthlessness much of
which has rooted in the crowd he now
hangs around with since many of Cobra
Kai's students are also bullies Robbie
attempts to talk sense and make him snap
out of it going to great lens to show
that he cares about Kenny's well-being
sadly Kenny is now just a ball of rage
and threatens all those who are once
close to him including Robbie at the end
of the season when Terry's sins are
revealed to COBRA Kai Kenny is the first
to rip his apparel off in shame and
lobit at his Fallen leader now he seems
totally lost even after Robbie
approaches him in the aftermath Kenny
dismisses his former friend as he's not
ready to confront everything will Kenny
undergo a transformation like many of
the former Cobra Kai students and will
he finally learn how to let go of his
anger and forgive Anthony for their past
we can only hope
Terry's reign of terror leaves plenty of
broken pieces to be picked up one of his
victims is a former Cobra kai fighter
Mike Barnes Daniel visits Mike believing
that Terry is going to recruit his
former student in his fight against
Daniel and Johnny after a brief
misunderstanding Daniel learns that Mike
has put his karate days behind him and
is now a family man who operates a
furniture store he is living a busy
happy life away from all the drama
however during his conversation with
Daniel he reveals information that could
jeopardize Terry's future with Cobra Kai
in turn Terry retaliates by having
Mike's Furniture Store burned to the
ground in the final episodes of the
Season Mike is furious over the loss of
his business he goes to Terry's house to
beat him to a bloody pulp Johnny and
chosen join him but it doesn't go the
way they envisioned as Terry has plenty
of muscle on standby ultimately Mike
Johnny and Chozen survived the bout but
with plenty of bruises cuts and blood to
show for their efforts Mike horse also
walks away with one of Terry's valuable
paintings hopefully Mike was a merely a
means to an end for the writers the
police don't go into specifics about the
crimes Terry is charged with but arson
should be one of them in addition Daniel
promises to help Mike get back on his
feet perhaps Mike will join Daniel at
the dealership anything is possible and
we can only hope that the former bad boy
of karate has a better future ahead of
him
perhaps one of the best things about
season 5 of Cobra Kai is that Johnny and
Carmen learn that they are going to have
a baby while at first terrified Johnny
quickly resolves to be a far better
father to the youngster than he was to
Robbie he experiences a real
transformation in his life he researches
child proofing his home to make it safer
for an infant plus Johnny shows that
he's serious about fatherhood and sets
out to make things right between Robbie
and Miguel before breaking the news to
them once he does they are Overjoyed
this leads to some of the brightest
moments of the entire season it also
gives Johnny a better reason to confront
kobakai and ensure that his child grows
up in a community that isn't terrorized
by thugs trained by brutal dojos when
Carmen and Johnny go to the doctor for
an ultrasound Johnny insinuates that the
baby will be a boy but the doctor says
it's too soon to know of course Johnny
clarifies that whether it's a boy or a
girl he's ready for the adventure of
being a parent now the only question is
what will they name the baby in a show
that's all about honoring the legacy of
The Karate Kid films of the 80s it'd be
a surprise if the writers don't take
this opportunity to include another
reference to the history of the
franchise it'd be presumptuous for us to
make any guesses at this stage but there
are plenty of options on the table
[Music]